And his brother and went to feed their father's flock and shuck him.
So they took off and Israel said unto Joseph,
do you know what the I brethren feed the flock and check them common,
I will send thee unto him.
And he said he had and he said to him,
here,
up here on mine,
and when they saw him afar off,
even before he came near onto them,
they conspired against him to slay him.
Rough people act then,
right?
This is,
this sort of thing is happening quite frequently.
Um,
and they said to one another,
behold the dreamer cometh.
Come now,
therefore let us slay him,
cast him into some pit and we will say some evil beast has devoured him and we
shall see what becomes of his dreams.
So there's an echo of the Kate enables story there obviously.
You know what I mean?
It's not quite as clear because in the Kate enables store able is clearly just
doing well.
And here you can't quite get a handle on Joseph's character.
You can't tell if he is actually the elect or if he's just a spoiled Brat with
delusions of grandeur.
You know,
and,
but it doesn't matter because his brothers are so irritated at his,
the fact that he's favored and perhaps even the fact that he might be someone
destined for,
for something special,
that they find it perfectly reasonable to destroy that.
And it's so hard.
It's so interesting how often that motif of pulling down an ideal manifest
itself in these old stories,
right?
It's,
it's,
the pattern is established in the Cain and Abel Story.
It just repeats and repeats and repeats.
And I think that's dead true.
I think it just repeats all the time,
is that people are annoyed about how tragic their lives are.
They're annoyed that they're subject to malevolence and they're annoyed that
they're not doing as well as other people are doing.
And that makes them,
that puts them exactly into this state of mind.
Now,
maybe with modern people,
if you're going to kill someone because you're resentful as a modern person,
you don't generally slay them and throw them into a pit.
You know,
what you do is you just killed them slowly over a few decades.
And it isn't obvious to me that that's any better.
So I've seen plenty of married couples who were in that situation.
It's like,
it's like,
Whoa,
there,
this Mitch Hedberg,
he used to complain about turtleneck phase.
It was like being strangled by a really weak midget,
and
it's probably really politically incorrect joke,
but it's a funny joke.
So,
uh,
and then you see,
you see relationships that are like that.
It's like each person has their hands around the neck of the other person,
but they don't have enough courage to actually to squeeze it.
Just put enough pressure on to s cut the circulation off a tiny bit.
So the person just gets like a die over 30 year period.
Something like that.